[Music]  did you wash your hands with soap did  you dry them it hurt all vegetables who  ordered all vegetable I did so are we  going to talk about it what the elephant  in the room what an elephant mom's new  job  it's time to make some wrong things  right help me bring supers back into the  sunlight we need to change people's  perceptions about superheroes and  Elastigirl is our best play better than  me I'll watch the kids no problem do it  dad they want us to do it I don't know  that way why would they change math math  is math math is math hello hey honey  catch everything's great  he's in excellent health that is freaky  you know it's crazy right to help my  family I gotta leave it to fix the law I  gotta break it you got to before kids  can have that choice thank you young man  combustion imminent what does that mean  it means fire Robert  [Music]  the screen slider interrupts this  program for an important announced that  it might get weird I'll be there  [Music]